lionel hutz is unstoppable and the best
part is
if you don't win your case your pizza is
free you'd be surprised how often that
works you really would
so contrary to popular belief lionel
hutz ateer well it's finally happening
today we are going to rank
all of the fictional lawyers on tv now
usually when you see these sort of tier
rankings
they're people's opinions but that is
not the case today
these are absolutely true as a matter of
law because of course
i have the power of attorney the power
of attorney
though the same time i have no idea what
i'm doing if only there were some sort
of youtube channel that specialized in
tier rankings that
could lend a hand i might be able to
help with that
oh tierzoo what are you doing here got
any tips on how i should rank all of
these fictional tv lawyers
tier lists are best used to compare
characters in games where each character
has a unique set of abilities and a lot
of variation in their stats
attributes like mobility raw power and
defense heavily influence how well a
character can match up against the rest
of the game's roster the devs designed
the characters to hopefully be fairly
equal in viability but the best players
will still naturally gravitate towards
the characters that have advantages
where it counts
those characters called top tiers are
gonna comprise your a and s
tier characters that have a lot of
potential but maybe have one or two
major weaknesses are gonna take up your
middle tiers
as will the sword of jack of all trades
characters and in the bottom tiers
that's where you'd find the characters
that nobody in their right mind would
play competitively
usually because they're hugely lacking
in power or have a massively exploitable
flaw in their strategy
yeah i'm not sure that that entirely
applies in this particular case
but what the heck let's give it a try
sorry man i don't make the rules
well thank you for stopping by tierzoo
so today we're ranking fictional tv
lawyers and we'll be doing that using
several criteria first of all
law skills self-explanatory we're
ranking lawyers second of all
fighting ability this includes of course
intelligence power defense mobility
vitality and stealth and then finally
third do they have any sort of special
ability that would give them an
advantage in
or outside of the courtroom alright with
the rules established let's get in and
rank these lawyers
phoenix wright a long time favorite of
viewers of this channel recent law grad
high fighting ability seems to have
reasonable intelligence seems to be
reasonably fit
the problem is his law skills are
extremely extremely
lacking objection being
a new recent law grad it seems like
there's almost someone else
controlling him uh telling him what to
do because he
has absolutely no idea what he's doing
he's often told what the evidence is
by witnesses to the case has no
comprehension of the rules of evidence
and is a terrible trial lawyer he's even
been accused of murder himself though
special abilities do include bike riding
and excellent hair though this is not
enough to save phoenix wright from
absolute f-tier garbage ace attorney
more like
attorney monster
[Music]
theodore ted buckland from the tv show
scrubs
the in-house lawyer for the hospital
sacred heart
actually lawyer skills were not too too
bad middle of the pack here
often gave reasonably good advice to the
doctors and administrators of sacred
heart
look if you know about something by not
reporting it you're every bit as
culpable now is there anything you want
to tell me
unfortunately no one ever ever followed
ted's advice
known as the hospital sad sack you're
only as good as your ability to get your
clients to actually follow your advice
and ted was simply never able to get
anyone to follow any of his advice
those special abilities include flop
sweat ted you ready to get started
whenever you're ready nina his ability
to
basically be invisible at all times and
of course his ability to sing
like an angel when you wish upon
a star rip sam lloyd and one of my
favorite portrayals of any lawyer on tv
ever notwithstanding dtir
bob loblaw from arrested development bob
loblaw needs no introduction especially
with respect to bob lobaugh's law blog
of course the blah blah blah blah
wow you sir are a mouthful he can do
anything that barry zuckerkorn can do
plus skew younger he gets extremely high
material from the fact
that he's able to bill out of just about
everything why should you
go to jail for a crime someone else
noticed
still his lawyering skills themselves
are a little bit underwhelming
sea tier
maggie leiser from arrested development
known as one of the most feared
attorneys in orange county
being able to navigate the legal waters
in orange county despite her apparent
blindness but of course
she wasn't actually blind i submit into
evidence
this wine glass with the defendant's
fingerprints
this gambit gave her high stealth but
very very poor mobility especially
given the fact that her special ability
her seeing eye dog justice
actually happened to be blind in this
case no avoiding
f-tier lawyer
[Music]
eli stone from the eponymous tv show on
abc
i didn't really see this one and
apparently no one else
saw this either has a good last name
lawyering skills were apparently
okay though his special ability did
include hallucinations
which is actually a bit of a nerf in and
of itself
are you god well someone has said so
so i don't know d-tier
saul goodman slash jimmy mcgill from
breaking bad and better call saul
hi i'm saul goodman did you know that
you have rights here
jimmy saul's lawyering abilities are top
notch despite
not going to a top law school the
university of american samoa
go land crabs he is able to dig in
when he is willing to put in the time
and the effort to get the results and
his knowledge of civil procedure and
just
interpersonal relationships is
absolutely top notch and
later in the game saul gets access to
one of the best partners in the entire
build
hewl though because jimmy is so
absolutely
unscrupulous that does knock him down a
peg
so close to getting estier but easily
makes a tier
barry zuckerkorn from arrested
development perhaps the worst law skills
of
any attorney on this entire list there's
a reason why the blues have just the
worst
attorneys
and barry zuckerkorn is absolutely no
exception here
i had a really interesting date last
night a woman who
actually works two jobs
he doesn't read contracts he gives
terrible terrible legal advice
he does have a special ability and that
is dance management but because he is
more interested in
running a dance studio than he is
actually practicing law
f-tier
[Music]
and elise keating from how to get away
with murder i covered the show and a
real lawyer reacts honestly it almost
caused me an
aneurysm i lied this isn't a past case
but when i took last week
after gina fired appraisals are there
law students there
this show is ridiculous and the
character annelise keating i don't think
actually knows anything about the law
despite the fact that she is a
putative law professor but she makes up
for her terrible or
non-existent lawyering skills with a
special ability
group attack she basically just corrals
all of her law students to
fight for her leading to the interesting
tech of
group cyclone this is not an advanced
trial skills class
in fact this is not a class at all this
is a sacrifice also let's just say she
has rocket punch
absolute deter trash
harvey specter and mike ross from suits
these guys are
all over the map harvey specter is known
as the best closer
at the law firm i'm not just a lawyer to
jerome okay i'm
i'm more like robert duvall the
godfather
but he is almost never able to actually
close things his actual legal skills in
the courtroom are
subpar he likes to bluster without
actually knowing
uh when to object rarely makes the right
objection makes speaking objections and
is just an okay at best trial lawyer
mike ross on the other hand is supposed
to be this godlike attorney he has a
photographic memory
but the thing is a photographic memory
doesn't actually help you
as an attorney as we saw from some of
the very first episodes despite the fact
that he could remember things he didn't
actually know the things
in the first place when it came to
actually litigating usually
the trial starts and there's a judge
and then you know people say things
you've never done this before have you
he needed help from the paralegals he
didn't know anything about legal
research which is what most lawyers do
and he isn't great at brief writing
these guys uh beats here
the unfrozen caveman lawyer from
saturday night live lawyer
key rock was a caveman he was frozen
during the ice age and scientists were
able to thaw him out as a result he's a
stranger in a strange land and he's
confused by
our modern accoutrement your world
frightens and confuses me
sometimes the honking horns of your
traffic
make me want to get out of my bmw
he uses that to great advantage his
special ability is of course confusion
he uses that confusion or
confusion if you will to confuse the
jury into
basically finding for his clients uh in
every single trial he's ever
participated in despite his appearance
extremely high intelligence leading to
great fighting ability though he does
have
pretty low vitality as a result of you
know frankly being frozen
and one of two lawyers on this list
portrayed by phil hartman
actually not to spoil anything but i'm
not sure that a character
voiced by phil hartman has ever lost a
trial but in particular the unfrozen
caveman lawyer uses his personal history
to the best of effect
never losing at trial ester for sure
[Music]
bobby donald from the practice bobby
donald played by dylan mcdermott let's
say
i don't know c tier mainly on account of
the fact that dylan mcdermott is not
dermot mulrooney
lionel hutz from the simpsons now this
is obviously everyone's
go-to punching bag in terms of lawyers
that are terrible at their jobs
his own law firm is called i can't
believe it's a law firm and
he doesn't appear to know anything about
the law itself
mr simpson don't you worry i watched
matlock in a bar last night the sound
wasn't on but i think i got the gist of
it but there is an extremely
interesting wrinkle to lionel hutz and
that is
i don't think lionel hutz has ever lost
a case he successfully represented bart
in a copyright suit regarding itchy and
scratchy he successfully represented
homer in his case against the restaurant
for unlimited shrimp the most egregious
case of
fraudulent advertising since the
never-ending story and he successfully
represented homer again
in a case against the devil lionel hutz
is unstoppable and the best part is
if you don't win your case your pizza is
free you'd be surprised how often that
worked
you really would so contrary to popular
belief lionel hutz atier
the entire cast of ally mcbeal frankly
all of these lawyers are basically
interchangeable reasonable
law skills though they couldn't help
themselves from just engaging in all
kinds of antics in the courtroom
sometimes doing things that would get
you disbarred
some even cheat objection move to strike
so yeah uh d-tier
perry mason from perry mason and a whole
bunch of
other things perry mason is the oldest
character
in the entire build none of these other
characters would exist
without perry mason he's the one that
created the whole idea of a tv
fictional lawyer harry mason is also
extremely successful
lawyer skills are above average i'd say
certainly no one can dispute his results
here he almost always is able to
successfully defend his clientele though
he is of course hampered by the
eponymous perry mason moment
you didn't kill thompson but you did mr
wells
when you have another witness on the
stand and through a combination of
lawyer skills
and just straight up badgering you get
them to confess
to the crime that your client is accused
of now anyone can represent a client
who is innocent it takes real skill to
represent someone who is clearly not
innocent and perry mason benefits from
always having innocent clients so perry
mason really benefits from his
domino-like special ability
luck he's lucky in the clients that he
represents he's lucky in that he's able
to
elicit confessions from basically
everyone except for his clients that's
not the way these things work
so despite being the er tv fictional
lawyer
i'm gonna knock him down a peg b-tier
ben matlock from matlock matlock
basically is just a continuation
of perry mason it seems to be perry
mason except in the south
i guess matlock is ethical he's a
straight shooter and he's a hell of an
investigator
matlock is basically a clefairy pokemon
in
that he is able to cast his special
ability char
folksy folksy southern charm all in all
i'll give
matlock one more than perry mason a tier
marshall erickson from how i met your
mother marshall is one of the
few lawyers that we get to see grow up
that
we see him studying in law school we see
him pass the bar and we see him
enter the world of private practice
marshall is the main character in one of
the greatest episodes about being a law
student being courted by the big firms
where he's wined and dined by john cho
eats kobe lobster and then does the walk
of shame
after drinking far too much much of what
i do
does not make me cry his lawyering
skills are top notch he has several
special abilities including the fact
that he can yell lawyer when people have
been lawyered
kaboom you've been lawyered and of
course powerful
slaps i'll let you slap me in the face
as hard as you can you have my attention
i don't really care how you met your
mother but marshall eriksen is ester
baby
[Music]
harvey birdman from harvey birdman here
harvey's
lawyering skills are mediocre at best
avenger
my personal digital assistant um
how do you make a t again do you push
that and then leave it down or do
he bats about a 500 when it comes to
taking things to trial usually the trial
gets
way laid by all the crazy things that
are happening as a result of the
superheroes involved
but his fighting abilities are top-notch
he's powered by the sun
he can shoot energy beams from his
wrists he can create
a solar powered shield and harvey
bergman can fly
he's one of the main attorneys at 7-7
the law firm though it does appear that
he got his law degree from a
correspondence course which is never a
good sign
but even that can't take away his power
of attorney
the power of attorney see tier
jackie childs from seinfeld clearly a
stand-in for
johnny cochran reasonably good lawyering
skills we covered this
in a real lawyer reacts the problem is
whenever he represents kramer he always
loses and he couldn't even defend the
bunch from a law that doesn't actually
exist good samaritan law you don't have
to help anybody that's what this
country's all about
that's deplorable unfathomable
improbable hold on
as we discussed in that episode there
really aren't any good samaritan laws
that require you to affirmatively help
out people who have been injured in a
crash
so the fact that the entire seinfeld
gang went to jail for
over a year doesn't bode well for jackie
childs
b-tier at best
[Music]
jerry kellman from succession she is the
general counsel to weigh star royco
feel it and she seems to know where all
of the bodies are buried jerry could
very clearly run the entire waystar
royco company though she will absolutely
never be given that chance she gives
reasonably good legal advice whether
it's a proxy war or
whether the entire united states
congress wants to come down on the
company as a result of what's going on
it cruises this may not be the best
situation but there are harder jobs and
you get a
load of cake feel it her special
abilities include opportunism and
whatever's going on between her
and roman if you've seen the show you
know what i'm talking about
jerry kellman is just absolutely the
best but she's never going to be given
an opportunity to get to the top and the
same thing holds true here
a tiered misses out on esteer
[Music]
jeff winger from community this one's
tough because the entire premise of the
show is that jeff winger
is not actually a lawyer so it's
extremely tempting to just dq him from
this list
are you a good person being sued
oppressed or beaten
i can help and that's the winger
guarantee
though if memory serves i guess in the
last season he does actually get his bar
license back
starts to private practice then leaves
to become a professor at greendale once
again
but the thing is anytime we actually see
jeff winger do something that is
lawyer-like he tends to be pretty bad at
it i discovered at a very early age that
if i talk long enough i could make
anything
right or wrong so either i'm god or
truth is relative and in either case
sometimes he's able to convince the
group to do what he wants and sometimes
they just simply don't listen to him so
law skills are lacking he doesn't appear
to have any special abilities whatsoever
deter it best
alan shore and denny crane from boston
legal these guys
are scumbags they are womanizers they
are conniving and they are loathsome
but their closing arguments are the
stuff of legends there
seems to be no rule that they won't
break in order to
get the right result for their client
look sometimes you want the scumbag
lawyer
a tier
alicia floric the good wife alicia here
is able to do a great job in navigating
the politics of law firm life which is
not something you see all that often and
she does a reasonably good job
in the courtroom as well a little shaky
at the start but eventually rises to the
level of equity partner in her firm
so this was a close call but i'm going
with btier
[Music]
jack mccoy from law and order here jack
mccoy's lawyering skills are absolutely
unparalleled perhaps one of the most
realistic but also
just his pure skill is unparalleled
given that his personal code is that if
there is a law out there he will
enforce it he tends to skew towards
lawful neutral where there's a law
i'll enforce it where there's a crime
i'll prosecute it
and where there's a victim i'll speak
for that victim
that's my bottom line he's not about to
use the legal system
for his own personal gain which leads
him to being a
civil servant a conduit through which
the law is administered to the rest of
society and
through his hard work and dedication he
eventually rises to the ranks of actual
district attorney for manhattan
special abilities include enormous
eyebrows and
a motorcycle so you know there's that
jack mccoy
easily makes esteer one of the best
lawyers in the entire build
hands down ester easy
[Music]
now this video isn't over originally i
went into detail and ranked all of the
district attorneys from every law and
order show
but the video was just too long and
wonky she's
relentless surviving an assassination
attempt by a colombian drug dealer you
know
as one does but lucky for you you can
watch the fully extended version over on
nebula which you can now get with a huge
discount when you get it with today's
sponsor
curiosity stream because sometimes going
into detail about every district
attorney that law and order has ever had
doesn't really work on youtube which is
why my creator friends and i teamed up
to build our own platform where creators
don't have to worry about demonetization
or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we are thrilled
to be partnering with curiositystream
because not only are our nebula versions
ad free and extended but they're also
released early before the youtube
versions because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content and put things
out that
we probably couldn't put on youtube and
it features lots of the top
educationalist creators out there like
mkbhd mary spender and h bomber guy
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
in long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos
you'll love the stuff on curiositystream
and we worked on a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream with a link
in the description
you'll also get a nebulous subscription
for free and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member
and right now curiosity stream is
offering 26 off their annual plans
that's
less than 15 for the entire year for
both curiosity stream
and nebula so if you click on the link
below you'll get access to both
curiosity stream
and nebula for 26 off or you can go to
curiositystream.com
legal eagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly
for under 15 per year so just click on
the link below plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel and check out the last
collaboration i did with tierzoo because
if you don't click on that video
i'll see you in court